did you know that you can create an  instance group template from a container  image I'll show you how  start at the compute section of the  cloud console click instance groups  create instance group name your group  select a location and under instance  definition choose create a new container  instance template name your template  select a machine type and then put in  the path to your container image my  container images on Google cloud  registry you can select a boot disk type  setup any ports and turn on HTTP and  HTTPS traffic if you need to click Save  and continue choose the number of  instances and you can set up Auto  healing if you'd like now click create  once your group is created you can click  instance templates and find your  template there I hope you get a chance  to try this out